Todos precisamos ser capazes de comunicar informações privadas sem medo de que alguém esteja escutando. Mas criar um
sistema à prova de falhas para isso não é fácil. No episódio de hoje do Qiskit na Sala de Aula, falaremos sobre como
algo chamado distribuição quântica de chaves pode
ajudar. Bem-vindo de volta ao Qiskit na Sala de Aula. Na série, abordaremos tópicos que você pode encontrar num curso universitário
relacionado à computação quântica. Cada vídeo vem com um módulo interativo com link na descrição, então
não deixa de conferir. Hoje, vamos nos aventurar no reino da criptografia quântica. A criptografia é o estudo
de técnicas de comunicação segura. Isso é incrivelmente importante em muitas partes da nossa vida. Toda vez que você usa uma
senha para entrar num site, faz um pagamento digital, ou quando governos transmitem inteligência militar, tudo isso é feito
por meio de algum protocolo criptográfico para que um bisbilhoteiro não consiga descobrir os nossos segredos. Mas há uma tensão aqui: como
garantir que a pessoa com quem queremos nos comunicar possa entender a nossa mensagem, mas ninguém mais possa?
Historicamente, criptógrafos criaram muitos protocolos diferentes para tentar tornar suas mensagens o mais imunes
possível a bisbilhoteiros. Às vezes, as duas partes que querem se comunicar de forma segura combinam algum
código com antecedência que, espera-se, seja tão complicado que um bisbilhoteiro não consiga decifrá-lo. Mas como
pessoas como Alan Turing e outros decifradores de código em tempos de guerra nos mostraram, até os códigos mais complicados podem ser
decifrados. Idealmente, gostaríamos de enviar mensagens criptografadas de tal forma que não haja absolutamente nenhum padrão
e nenhuma maneira de um bisbilhoteiro entender sem também ter uma chave aleatória secreta que apenas o remetente e o
receptor conhecem. Mas aí ficamos expostos a uma nova vulnerabilidade: como podemos enviar essa chave e ter certeza de que
ninguém a intercepta? Em 1984, Charles Bennett e Jill Brassard criaram um
método para enviar uma chave de forma segura com bits quânticos, que agora é chamado de BB84. O recurso chave desses
bits quânticos, ou qubits, que permite esse protocolo é que eles obedecem ao princípio de incerteza. Você não pode medir
um sistema quântico sem perturbá-lo. Hoje, começaremos com um exemplo de um código criptográfico simples. Depois,
mostrarei como a distribuição quântica de chaves e o princípio de incerteza podem nos permitir usar
criptografias quase invioláveis. Vou te guiar pelo protocolo BB84 em detalhes e, por fim, vamos executá-lo num computador quântico
real. Primeiro, vamos começar com um jogo que talvez você já tenha visto, chamado criptograma.
Você recebe uma sequência de letras aparentemente aleatórias, mas usando o seu conhecimento de padrões na língua
inglesa, pode substituir uma letra por outra para dar sentido à mensagem. Aqui está um exemplo. Esta é uma
mensagem secreta com uma cifra de substituição simples. Então todos os Rs representam uma letra, os Ms representam
outra, e assim por diante. Se queres tentar resolver isso por conta própria, pausa o vídeo agora.
Acontece que essa mensagem foi criptografada usando uma cifra muito simples chamada cifra de César, onde
o alfabeto é simplesmente deslocado por um certo número — neste caso, 9. Então A vira J, B
vira K, C vira L e assim por diante. Quanto mais longa a mensagem, mais fácil fica
ver o padrão. Então, com uma mensagem tão longa quanto a que temos, a cifra de César ou qualquer outra cifra que simplesmente
substitui uma letra do alfabeto por outra é bem simples de decifrar. Uma maneira mais segura de codificar uma mensagem secreta
é com o chamado bloco de uso único. Com um bloco de uso único, você pode ter um deslocamento diferente para cada letra da
mensagem. Só precisa dizer ao seu amigo qual foi o deslocamento em cada letra para que ele possa decodificar a mensagem.
Essa lista de deslocamentos é chamada de chave ou bloco. É chamado de bloco de uso único porque é usado uma vez e depois descartado.
Se for usado mais do que isso, padrões surgirão e podem tornar a criptografia decifrável. Com a criptografia de
bloco de uso único, tanto a mensagem criptografada quanto a chave individualmente são apenas uma sequência aleatória de nonsense. Mas
quando os juntamos, vemos uma mensagem secreta emergindo do ruído.
Vamos fazer um exemplo rápido. Digamos que já criei e enviei ao meu amigo esse bloco de uso único, que normalmente é escrito em
binário. E então quero enviar a mensagem "I love quantum". Então codificaria a mensagem
assim. Primeiro, convertemos as letras da nossa mensagem para binário. Cada letra de A a Z vai
corresponder aos números de 1 a 26 escritos em binário. Então A será 0, 0,
0, 1; B será 0, 0, 1,
0; C será 0, 0, 1, 1; e assim
por diante. E um espaço será apenas zeros.
Então é isso que a mensagem se torna. Codificamos a mensagem realizando um XOR entre cada bit da mensagem e
o bit correspondente no bloco de uso único. Se você nunca viu XOR antes, ele
significa "ou exclusivo". O XOR entre dois bits será 1 se apenas um
dos bits for 1, e zero se ambos forem zero ou ambos forem 1. Então o primeiro conjunto de cinco bits na mensagem codificada
se torna 1, 0,
0, 1, 1. Deixo o restante dos XORs para você fazer por conta própria. Mas o ponto é
que essa mensagem agora é apenas uma sequência aleatória de zeros e uns sem padrão algum. É completamente indecifrável por qualquer pessoa que
não tenha o bloco de uso único que usamos para criptografar a mensagem. Então, o que aprendemos até agora? Alguns esquemas de criptografia
são melhores que outros, e alguns podem ser deduzidos por uma pessoa inteligente que procura padrões na mensagem criptografada.
Mas uma chave verdadeiramente aleatória que desloca cada letra de uma mensagem secreta por uma quantidade aleatória diferente não pode ser
deduzida, porque não há padrões na mensagem. A única vulnerabilidade num esquema como este é garantir
que a chave usada para criptografar a mensagem não caia nas mãos erradas. É aqui que entra a distribuição quântica de
chaves. Usando qubits, Bennett e Brassard criaram uma forma para duas partes concordarem com uma chave e
terem razoável certeza de que uma terceira parte não estava ouvindo em segredo. Esse protocolo BB84 é um pouco complicado, mas
vamos percorrê-lo passo a passo. Para esta explicação, vamos trazer de volta nossos velhos amigos, Alice e
Bob. O protocolo começa com Alice preparando um conjunto de qubits para enviar a Bob. Esses qubits contêm a
informação que se tornará o bloco de uso único ou chave compartilhada deles. Alice primeiro gera duas sequências aleatórias de
mesmo comprimento. Uma é uma sequência aleatória de zeros e uns, e a outra é uma sequência aleatória de Xs e Zs representando a
base na qual ela vai preparar seus qubits. Em seguida, ela vai preparar cada qubit num estado quântico de acordo com a
combinação de base e valor de bit mostrada nesta tabela. Então, se o bit for zero e a base for Z, ela vai
preparar o qubit no estado zero. Ou se o bit for um e a base for X, ela o preparará no estado menos. Se
você não tiver certeza do que são essas bases e estados quânticos, tudo bem. O ponto principal que você precisa saber é que
as medições em cada base sempre têm apenas dois resultados possíveis: 0 ou 1 para a base Z, e mais ou menos para a base X.
Se você medir o estado zero na base Z, sempre obterá zero.
Mas se medir esse mesmo estado na base X, obterá um resultado aleatório — mais ou menos, cada um com 50% de
chance. Então Alice pode preparar uma sequência de qubits assim, onde aqui está a sequência aleatória de
zeros e uns e aqui está a sequência aleatória de Xs e Zs. Então o primeiro elemento em cada uma das
duas sequências dela foi 0 e X. Isso significa que ela vai preparar o primeiro qubit no estado mais, e
assim por diante. Depois de preparar todos os seus estados de qubit, Alice vai enviar esses qubits a Bob, e Bob vai escolher aleatoriamente entre X
e Z como a base para medir cada um. Então adicionamos algumas linhas à
tabela para representar as escolhas e medições de Bob. Então aqui estão as
medições e escolhas de base de Bob. E aqui estão os resultados das medições dos qubits que Alice enviou a ele. Por fim, Bob
pode converter cada medição num bit usando a mesma tabela que Alice usou para preparar seus qubits. Quando ele mede o
estado zero ou o estado mais, ele atribui o valor de bit zero. E onde ele mede o estado um ou o estado menos, ele coloca um
1. Então a sequência de bits final de Bob é esta última linha.
Nota que quando as bases da etapa de preparação de Alice e da etapa de medição de Bob coincidem, os bits deles também vão coincidir.
Mas se Alice escolher preparar em Z e Bob medir em X, ou vice-versa,
os bits correspondentes de Alice e Bob não serão necessariamente os mesmos. Portanto, uma forma de ambos concordarem com uma sequência de bits
para o bloco de uso único é se ligarem e dizerem um ao outro quais bases usaram para cada qubit.
Quando as bases coincidem, eles ficam com o bit; quando não coincidem, descartam.
Então, nesse caso, Alice e Bob concordarão com uma sequência de bits de 0, 0, 1, 0,
0. Como esse esquema protege contra bisbilhoteiros não detectados? Bem, vamos ver o que acontece quando tal bisbilhoteiro,
chamado Eve, intercepta os qubits que Alice envia a Bob. Ela não sabe em qual estado esses qubits estão ou como
Alice os preparou. Então, graças ao princípio de incerteza e a algo chamado teorema da não clonagem, ela não pode
simplesmente fazer uma cópia idêntica dos qubits para passar adiante a Bob. Se ela pudesse, então seria capaz de
bisbilhotar sem ser detectada. Em vez disso, ela adivinha uma base para medir cada qubit, os mede e depois
prepara um novo conjunto de qubits falsos para enviar a Bob. Existem outras formas mais sorrateiras de Eve tentar
aprender sobre os qubits, mas nenhuma delas contorna o princípio de incerteza.
Então, vamos assumir este método direto de espionagem de Eve. Aqui está uma tabela descrevendo
a preparação de Alice, a interceptação de Eve e a medição final de Bob. Então agora, quando
Alice e Bob conversam por telefone para comparar suas bases, vão decidir ficar com esses bits para a chave, mas os
bits não coincidem. Isso porque Bob estava medindo qubits que Eve preparou, não os qubits originais de Alice.
Se compararem um subconjunto dos bits em suas sequências de bits entre si, verão que alguns não coincidem e
concluirão que deve ter havido um bisbilhoteiro. Então, como Eve foi descoberta, Alice e Bob vão
descartar suas sequências de bits e recomeçar o protocolo do zero. Mas se Eve não tivesse escutado e o subconjunto de
bits que Alice e Bob compararam coincidisse, então poderiam prosseguir e usar os bits restantes que não
compararam como chave compartilhada. Uma vez que Alice e Bob têm uma chave compartilhada, Alice pode enviar mensagens criptografadas a Bob, e
Bob é o único que pode descriptografá-las usando a chave. Agora que passamos pelo protocolo, vamos tentar num
computador quântico. Há algumas coisas para ter em mente neste experimento. Primeiro,
o BB84 só é realmente útil se Alice e Bob estiverem longe um do outro. Para o experimento que vamos fazer, Alice
e Bob estão no mesmo chip quântico. Então, esse experimento não será útil para trocar informações privadas, mas é
ainda uma boa demonstração conceitual do BB84.
Segundo, computadores quânticos reais têm ruído. Então, mesmo que a base de preparação de Alice coincida com a base de medição de Bob
e não haja bisbilhoteiro, ainda há uma pequena chance de que eles meçam bits diferentes devido a erros no
computador quântico. Quando estiverem comparando suas sequências de bits para verificar a presença de bisbilhoteiros, precisam ter alguma tolerância a erros antes de
concluírem que deve ter havido um bisbilhoteiro interferindo e descartarem toda a chave. Agora, com essas
ressalvas, vamos começar com um experimento sem bisbilhoteiro. Primeiro, geramos aleatoriamente
três sequências de bits diferentes, cada uma com 20 bits. A primeira é a sequência de bits inicial de Alice.
A segunda é uma lista das bases nas quais Alice vai preparar seus qubits.
Aqui escolhemos zero para representar a base Z e um para representar a base X. A lista final é as bases em
que Bob vai medir cada qubit. Com base nessas três listas, podemos criar um diagrama de circuit com instruções para
a preparação de Alice e as medições de Bob. Todos os qubits começam no estado zero. Então, para preparar seus qubits na
base Z, Alice ou não faz nada para o estado zero, ou aplica um gate NOT ou X mostrado como as caixas azuis com rótulo X
para o estado um. Para preparar na base X, ela aplica um gate Hadamard, que leva zero para o estado mais,
ou um gate NOT seguido de um gate Hadamard para preparar o estado menos. Em seguida, ela envia os qubits a Bob. O próximo conjunto de caixas
no circuit representa as medições de Bob. Para medir na base Z, ele não precisa aplicar mais nenhum gate.
Ele apenas mede, o que é mostrado por essas caixas cinzas. Para medir na base X, ele primeiro aplica um gate Hadamard e
depois mede. Vamos executar esse circuit usando o Sampler primitivo do Qiskit em runtime. A saída é a sequência de bits
de medições de Bob. Então podemos comparar as sequências de bits de Bob com a sequência de bits inicial de Alice, descartando os bits
onde as bases deles não coincidiram. E vemos que os dois obtêm a mesma chave.
Lembra que este é hardware real, então ocasionalmente pode haver um bit que deveria coincidir, mas não coincide. Neste caso, todos os
bits coincidem, mas se você rodar isso de novo por conta própria, pode ter um erro. Mas, desde que a fidelidade esteja próxima de 1,
Alice e Bob podem ter razoável certeza de que não houve bisbilhoteiro. Agora vamos ver o que acontece se Eve interceptar os
qubits. Agora temos dois circuits. O primeiro mostra a preparação de Alice e a interceptação e
medição de Eve. O próximo mostra a preparação dos qubits falsos de Eve e a medição de Bob.
Podemos executar esses circuits como antes, e depois ver o que Alice e Bob obteriam ao comparar suas sequências de bits.
Desta vez, obtêm uma fidelidade de 0,6 periódico. Isso é muito mais baixo do que
o que pode ser explicado pelo ruído do computador quântico. Então eles concluem que Eve estava espionando. A computação quântica é
conhecida e frequentemente hiper-divulgada pelo seu potencial de resolver problemas difíceis. Mas a comunicação e a criptografia quânticas
muitas vezes recebem muito menos atenção, mesmo que o potencial que o quantum pode oferecer nessas áreas seja igualmente
significativo e empolgante. Hoje discutimos o protocolo mais antigo descoberto para distribuição quântica de chaves, que é
praticamente imune a espionagem não detectada. Se queres tentar enviar um código inviolável com
uma chave certificada quanticamente, acessa o módulo com link na descrição.
Obrigado por assistir e até a próxima!